oui
est ce que des gens vivent sur la ligne
sur la lune c'est une bonne question
tout a commencé lors de ma dernière
expédition nous avions voyagé jusqu'à
l'autre bout du monde
je m'étais donc éloigné pour chercher du
bois
incroyable alors qu'est ce que c'est
nous sommes partagés les pierres
équitable que c'est bon moi je suis sûr
qu'elle cache un secret il faut
retrouver les autres pour en avoir le
coeur net il ne nous reste plus qu'à les
suivre excusez moi vous n'avez pas et
vous ne l'avez pas vu c'est que vous
n'avez pas bien regardé on peut tout
faire si on veut
il suffit d'y croire très fort alors tu
veux bien me dire où je peux trouver la
pierre des taxis ont repris y situer au
pays des rêves on peut faire tout ce que
l'on désire s'intéresse à ces pierres
j'habite dans la lune il nous les faut
pour entrer chez nous je sais comment
les retrouver tout but incroyable
pourquoi s'arrête pile ce alors qu'est
ce qu'ils sont
en quoi est faite la lune il est
toujours bon de garder une part de
mystère dans nos vies mais est ce que
quelqu'un pourrait m'aider